I remember I had, he had instilled in me a respect for ML and something like an interest, but I had never really gotten into it. I'd never really actually taken the time to learn. And so I see this, I'm like, oh, that sounds like something really interesting. Like I want to, I want to learn about this. And so it's like, yeah, let's do Rust. And very quickly fell in love and started using it for everything I could. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 106, recorded on November 2nd, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we interview Jane Lazari-Lusby and talk about the Rust programming language. So I ended up not being late, Connor.
我记得我有，他曾向我灌输了对 ML 的尊重和某种兴趣，但我从未真正深入其中。我从没真正花时间去学习。当我看到这个时，我想，哦，这听起来真的很酷。就像我想，我想了解这个。所以就像，好吧，我们来学 Rust 吧。然后我很快就爱上了它，并开始尽可能地在所有地方使用它。欢迎收看 ADSP 播客第 106 期，录制于 2022 年 11 月 2 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起采访简·拉扎里-卢斯比（Jane Lazari-Lusby），聊聊 Rust 编程语言。所以我最后没有迟到，康纳。
I mean, I could have 100% not been late. That was late. That was late. This was five minutes late. That was late. This is a first. Wait, I'm recording. Is everybody recording? This is your narrator connor here unfortunately not everyone's mics were recording thanks i'm blaming bryce because bryce was late bryce threw us off our game but jane's mic we got sorted out in a few minutes or so so if you're thinking to yourself, how come Jane's not saying anything? That's because we didn't have her audio recorded.
我的意思是，我本来可以百分之百不迟到的。那是迟到。那是迟到。这迟到了五分钟。那是迟到。这还是头一次。等等，我在录音吗？大家都在录音吗？我是你们的旁白康纳，不幸的是，并不是所有人的麦克风都在录音。谢谢。我怪布莱斯，因为布莱斯迟到了。布莱斯打乱了我们的节奏，但简的麦克风我们在几分钟内就搞定了。所以如果你心里在想，为什么简什么都没说？那是因为我们没有录下她的音频。
But hopefully it isn't too confusing. Because this needs to be on record. This is the first time, and it's terrible, the first time we have a Rust individual on, someone from the Rust community. I got to turn the AC off or the audio is going to be terrible. Oh my goodness. Okay, continue.
但愿这不会太让人糊涂。因为这需要记录下来。这是第一次，而且太糟糕了，这是我们第一次邀请 Rust 圈内人士，也就是 Rust 社区的人来做客。我得关掉空调，否则音频会糟透了。哦天哪。好吧，继续。
I apologize, Jane. I take this podcast very seriously. I feel less bad about recording a whole set of podcasts without Bryce now because he... Wait, wait, what was that? What was that? Yes, Bryce. Well, wait, this is going to be a rough takeoff. Have you listened to any of the ADSP episodes? Okay, so you... So I could have been 100% on time, but I knew I needed to stop for ice cream on the way home. It wasn't even something important. So I know you've been on Are We Podcast yet,
我很抱歉，简。我对这个播客非常认真。现在我觉得没有布莱斯录制整套播客让我没那么内疚了，因为他……等等，等等，刚才那是什么？刚才那是什么？是的，布莱斯。好吧，等等，这将是一个艰难的起步。你听过任何一集的 ADSP 吗？好吧，所以你……所以我本来可以百分之百准时的，但我知道我回家路上得停下来买冰淇淋。这甚至算不上什么重要的事情。所以，我知道你还没上过 Are We Podcast，
and you've been on Rustation Station. Have you been on others outside the Rust community as well? You've only listened to... You've listened to less than two, like episodes or you mean podcasts? It's all right, Connor. Not everybody listens to podcasts. I mean, it's just. It's like you invite,
你也上过 Rustation Station。你还去过 Rust 社区之外的其他节目吗？你只听过……你听过的节目不到两个，你是说播客吗？没关系，康纳。不是每个人都听播客。我的意思是，这就像你邀请，
we invite Jane on this podcast and the first thing you do, Connor, is you're like, what? You don't listen to podcasts? I understand that some people don't listen to podcasts, but I was expecting her to say that, oh, I've been on 12 podcasts or something,
我们邀请简来上这个播客，而你做的第一件事，康纳，就是说，什么？你不听播客？我理解有些人不听播客，但我原本期望她说，哦，我已经上过 12 个播客之类的，
a bunch of Python ones, a bunch of C++ ones. And so actually, I've listened to a handful here and there. I was just shocked to hear that you listen to less than two. All right, wait. So I have a bit of a problem. Can we introduce our guest first? No, I have a bit of a problem. Can we introduce our guest first? No. I have a bit of a problem. So dear listener, you just heard me ask, can we introduce our guest first?
一堆 Python 的，一堆 C++ 的。所以实际上，我零星听过一些。听说你听过的不到两个，我当时惊呆了。好吧，等等。所以我有个小问题。我们能先介绍一下我们的嘉宾吗？不，我有个小问题。我们能先介绍一下我们的嘉宾吗？不。我有个小问题。所以亲爱的听众，你刚刚听到我问，我们能先介绍一下我们的嘉宾吗？
And then you heard, and that was all Bryce telling us stuff that's unimportant. I hope you're going to include the no. Let's get to formally introducing Jane though. So Jane, I don't know a percentage of our listeners are Rust developers. I'd probably say, what do you think, Bryce? 25% maybe have dabbled in a bit of Rust, because I'd say it's like 75% to 90% C++. And so because of that, some of them will have exposure to Rust. But Jane is a number of things. She's a collaboration director for the Rust Foundation. We're catching you right at the end of your Rust library and
然后你听到的是，全都是布莱斯在讲一些不重要的东西。我希望你会把那个“不”字剪进去。不过，我们还是正式介绍一下简吧。所以简，我不知道我们的听众中有多少比例是 Rust 开发者。我大概会说，你觉得呢，布莱斯？可能 25% 的人涉猎过一点 Rust，因为我觉得 C++ 开发者大概占 75% 到 90%。正因如此，他们中的一些人会接触过 Rust。但简有很多身份。她是 Rust 基金会的协作 director（合作总监）。我们正好在你任期结束时采访你，你的 Rust 库和
library API team terms. And previously, you are a Rust developer full-time now, I think, and previously a C++ developer, which is fantastic for this podcast. And so just to fill you in, how did this all happen? I guess the last time we recorded, I started talking about how we were going to launch a poll because I've started working on a little Rust library. Connor and I are kind of, I don't know, done with C++. I'm like joking, but... You can't say that. You can't say that.
库 API 团队任期。在此之前，我想你现在是一名全职 Rust 开发者，而以前是一名 C++ 开发者，这对于本播客来说简直太棒了。为了让你了解情况，这一切是怎么发生的？我想上次录音时，我开始谈论我们要发起一项民意调查，因为我开始着手编写一个小的 Rust 库。我和康纳有点，怎么说呢，受够了 C++。我开玩笑的，但是……你不能这么说。你不能这么说。
We're definitely not done with C++. I might be. Fast forward like a couple months from now. We put out a poll. We actually don't even know how that's doing last time i checked it was the poll was to inform jane because our listeners know it was uh what do you prefer to our listeners a we turn this temporarily into a rust podcast b connor starts a new rust only podcast or c both and i think it was like 38 a 36 b and C was whatever the remainder of that was. So we're going to be temporarily for like,
我们绝对没有受够 C++。可能我受够了。快进到几个月后的现在。我们发布了一项民意调查。我们甚至不知道它现在进展如何，我上次查的时候，这项民意调查是为了征求简的意见，因为我们的听众知道，它是……呃，你更倾向于让我们的听众投票：a. 我们暂时把这变成一个 Rust 播客，b. 康纳开始一个新的纯 Rust 播客，还是 c. 两者皆是。我想结果大概是 38% 选 a，36% 选 b，c 就是剩下的票数。所以我们将会暂时，持续大概，
I don't know how many episodes, the next 10, 20, going to be turning this into a Rust podcast. And we thought we started like live. We weren't, I was live coding and I was just, oh yes, we have to update. The first thing we tried to do was get the first element from a vector. The first thing we tried to do was get the first element from a vector. The first thing Connor tried to do.
我不知道多少集，接下来的 10 集、20 集，把这里变成一个 Rust 播客。我们以为我们是“现场”开始的。我们当时不是，我正在进行实时编码，然后我就，哦对了，我们得更新。我们尝试做的第一件事就是从向量（vector）中获取第一个元素。我们尝试做的第一件事就是从向量中获取第一个元素。康纳尝试做的第一件事。
Correct. And since then, and so initially I thought it was you had to go into iter.next.unwrap. But then Bryce, while we were doing this live, Bryce was like, why can't you just do bracket, zero bracket? Bryce realized the reason I never tried that was because in C++ the way I would do it is just vector dot front and when I tried to do
没错。从那以后，起初我以为你得用 iter.next.unwrap。但后来布莱斯，在我们直播的时候，布莱斯说，为什么你不能直接用方括号零方括号呢？布莱斯意识到我从来没试过那个的原因是，在 C++ 中我通常会用 vector 点 front，当我尝试这样做时，
that I found the next method and in order to use that you have to do iter and then unwrap but then on Twitter and on Reddit multiple people have pointed out to me have to say the Rust community lot nicer than C++ community so far. Yep.
我发现了 next 方法，要使用它你必须先用 iter 然后 unwrap，但接着在 Twitter 和 Reddit 上，有许多人向我指出，我必须说，到目前为止，Rust 社区比 C++ 社区友善得多。没错。
Just from what I had. Well, we're going to wait to go on a tangent. We're going to wait to go on a tangent. But multiple people pointed out that there was also a third method called first. So that is the actual equivalent of front on Vec. But that's implemented on your structs, a.k.a. vector. I might be getting some details wrong there. Anyways, the point is that was our last episode, at least that we recorded.
就在我……好吧，我们先不扯远。我们先不扯远。但许多人指出，其实还有第三种方法叫 first。所以这才是 Vec 上 front 的真正等价物。但这其实是实现在你的结构体（structs）上的，也就是向量。我在某些细节上可能说得不对。无论如何，重点是那是我们的上一集，至少是我们录制的上一集。
So that was episode 101. And then in the midst of all this, Bryce was kind of making fun of me. He's like, we can't air this. You look like an idiot. And I was like, first of all, Bryce, I don't know fun of me. He's like, we can't air this. You look like an idiot. And I was like, first of all, Bryce, I don't know anything about Rust. This is just like how anyone learns a language. I don't think I said that verbatim.
所以那是第 101 集。然后在这期间，布莱斯一直在取笑我。他说，我们不能播这个。你看上去像个白痴。然后我说，首先，布莱斯，我不知道取笑我。他说，我们不能播这个。你看上去像个白痴。然后我说，首先，布莱斯，我对 Rust 一无所知。这就像任何人学习一门语言的过程一样。我想我当时说的不是这个原话。
You didn't say it. This is the part where Connor's going to edit in me saying it verbatim. No, you didn't say it, but you implied that I would be ashamed of what had happened. No. And I said, no, that's just,
你没说。这就是康纳会剪辑把我说的原话放进来的部分。不，你没说，但你暗示我会对发生的事情感到羞耻。没有。我说的是，不，那只是，
that's how learning the language goes. All right. Little technical difficulties. Speaking of things that people should be ashamed of, at some point on this episode, I need to talk about the Shinkansen Android app. Like the Japanese bullet train? Yes.
那是学习语言的必经过程。好的。遇到一点小技术困难。说到人们应该感到羞耻的事情，在这个节目的某个时刻，我得聊聊新干线 Android 应用。就像日本子弹头列车那样？是的。
All right. We will maybe get to that. Anyways, we're wrapping up this Android app. Like the Japanese bullet train? Yes. Yes. All right. We will maybe get to that. Anyways, we're wrapping up this so that we can get Jane to tell us her story from C++ to Rust. And actually,
好吧。我们也许会聊到那个。无论如何，我们快结束这个 Android 应用。就像日本子弹头列车那样？是的。是的。好吧。我们也许会聊到那个。无论如何，我们结束这个，是为了让简给我们讲讲她从 C++ 转向 Rust 的故事。其实，
you can go all the way back before C++ if there was stuff before that as well. The point is, we've slowly started turning into a Rust podcast and it was a little bit
如果你愿意，甚至可以一直追溯到 C++ 之前，如果那时候也有接触的话。重点是，我们慢慢开始变成一个 Rust 播客，在我们初次尝试时还磕磕绊绊的。所以我想是布莱斯说，你知道的，我们在这里干什么呢？通常人们会直接去跟那些懂行的人交流。他指出了这一点，我说，嗯，非常有道理。现在好了，几集过后，我们正在跟一个真正懂行的人交流。我们要把这期节目拆分成几个不同的部分，
of a stumble on our first tackle at it. And so I think it was Bryce that said, you know, what are we doing here? You know, usually people just go and talk to people that know what they're talking about. And he pointed that out, and I said, well, that's a very valid point. And now here we are, a couple episodes later, talking to someone that actually knows what she's doing. And we're going to split this up into a couple different episodes.
所以第一部分，如果你愿意，能不能跟我们讲讲你是怎么走上 Rust 这条路的，然后你可以跟我们聊聊做库开发的工作、为什么 Rust 这么棒、为什么 Rust 社区的人这么友善——我的意思是，C++ 社区怎么了？我不确定，你可能没关注我……不，其实你在 Twitter 上关注了我。我发推文说我不再经常用 Twitter 了。好吧，所以你大概没看到 Twitter。我发了两个截图，是在发布第 101 集的时候，我把它标题为《C++ 开发者尝试 Rust》，因为我想用标题党吸引每个人来听。Rust 圈的人觉得挺搞笑的，他们说，嘿，你应该去发一下，因为我发了，我同时在 r/rust 和 r/cpp 上跨平台发布了。哦天哪。
So the first one, if you want, want you know tell us your path that brought you to rust and then you can talk to us about working on the library stuff why rust is so awesome why are the people in rust so nice i mean what did the c plus plus i'm not sure you probably don't follow me on uh no actually do follow me on twitter i tweeted i don't use twitter much anymore go okay so you probably wouldn't have seen twitter i tweeted i don't use twitter much anymore go okay so you probably wouldn't have seen this i tweeted two different screenshots from posting episode 101 which i titled c plus plus developers try rust because i wanted to you know clickbait everyone in to listening to it the rust people they were having a good laugh and they were like hey you
Rust 圈的人说，哦，太棒了。这里有一堆反馈。你知道的，你犯了很多错误，但你还在学习。
should go try posting because i i posted it i cross posted on both slash rust and slash cpp oh god the rust people were like, Oh, this is great. Here's a bunch of feedback. You know, you've made a bunch of mistakes, but you're just learning.
没关系。然后下面有个子线程，他们说，你应该去 C++ 版块发一下。我说，我已经发了。他们就说，一路顺风。祝你好运。
It's okay. And then there was like a sub thread where they were like, you should go post this on C plus plus. And I was like, I already did. And there's like, Godspeed. Good luck.
你知道的，你在做上帝的工作。然后发到 C++ 版块的那条……我应该把它找出来读一下。其实，我去找找那条推文吧。太搞笑了。
You're, you know, you're doing the Lord's work. And then the, the post to C plus plus got, I should, I should bring it up and read it. Actually, I'll just go find the tweet. It's so funny.
我们去我的主页看看。我希望我不是在白白紧张。不，不。绝对有必要。搞笑的是我发了推文，其中一个人是 STL，也就是
Let's go to my profile. I hope I'm bracing unnecessarily. No, no. It's definitely necessary. And what's funny is that I tweeted, so one of the people STL aka
LavaWade，他在微软担任 C++ 库实现者，他评论道：有没有人听过这个，能总结一下里面有没有关于 C++ 的内容吗？搞笑的是，同一天我发了一条推文，引用或截屏了他对合并到 C++ 23 的 zip 功能的 PR 的评论，显然 Rust 早就有了这个功能，因为 Rust 是一门非常可爱的语言，他们知道什么才是重要的功能。所以，当我在那边表现得像，哇，太棒了，这太酷了，并且赢得了大量转发时，他却在这个讨论串里问：这里面有任何关于 Rust 的内容吗？第一个回复是：播客总长度 22 分钟。直到第 7 分钟，字面意思上全部都是在胡扯一些随机话题、Twitter 和其他无用的东西。哦，我的天哪。
LavaWade who works for Microsoft as a library implementer on C++, he commented, has there anyone that's listened to this that can summarize if there's anything about C++? And what's funny is the same day I tweeted out a quote or like a screen capture of him commenting on a PR that merged in zip to C++ 23, which obviously Rust already has because Rust is a very lovely language and they know the important things to have. And so at the same time, as I'm like being like, hey, yay, this is so awesome. And that got a bunch of retweets. He's on this thread asking, does this have anything about Rust? The first response, total length of the podcast is 22 minutes. Until minute seven, it's literally just blubbering about random topics, Twitter, and other useless stuff. Oh, my God.
然后他们接着总结说，我们在比较 vec.front 和尖括号零、方括号零、方括号零、方括号，还说了一些其他嘲讽的话，以及非常振奋人心的话，你知道的，鼓励和支持的话。其他人说他们听得尴尬癌都犯了。不管怎样，我坦然接受这些，我喜欢互联网。我的意思是，我们在录制的时候我也觉得尴尬……嗯，至少那条挺公道的。那个故事的结局是，我们很快就被移除了，我们被踢出了 CPP，因为显然如果内容不直接关于 C++，这里就没有它的容身之地。我还要
And then they proceed to summarize that we're comparing vec.front at sort of angle bracket zero, square bracket zero zero square bracket and sort of saying some other deriding stuff and very uplifting stuff you know encouraging supportive other people said they cringed anyways i i take this stuff in stride i love the internet i mean i i i cringe as we record this um so that one's at least fair the end of that story is that we promptly were removed we got kicked off of CPP because apparently if it's not directly about C++ it has no space and might I
补充一点，因为简不知道这一点，我们是现存排名第一的 C++ 播客。我觉得无论我们聊什么都应该被允许，除非是像我们推荐电影那样——虽然我们确实做过关于电影的节目。我觉得像 C++ 开发者艰难探索 Rust 这样的内容，当然，它不是关于 C++ 的，但重点是 Rust 圈的人很友善。
add because Jane doesn't know this we are the number one active C++ podcast out there I think we should just get like whatever we talk about unless if it's like our movie recommendations which admittedly we have done episodes about that stuff I think we should just get like whatever we talk about, unless if it's like our movie recommendations, which admittedly we have done episodes about that stuff. I think that like C++ devs trying to make their way through Rust. Sure, it's not about C++, but the point is Rust people, lovely.
至于 C++，我不会说他们不友善，除了那几个说了刻薄话的人之外。无论怎样，把时间交给你，简。带我们回到你出生的时候，随便啦，比如你 13 岁的时候，无论你想选哪个年龄，以及你是如何接触到 Rust 的故事。好吧，我从我上大学前不久开始接触编程讲起，我读了计算机科学学位，C++ 基本上是我在学期间学的主要语言，所以我的职业生涯也是从写 C++ 代码开始的。我不会说我曾经达到过任何专家级别，或者对 C++ 特别投入。当时它基本上只是一份工作。所以，在我的 C++ 职业生涯中，我知道 L 值和 R 值的时间晚得令人尴尬，诸如此类。所以，
C++, I won't call them not lovely, except for those couple people who did say some mean things. Anyways, over to you, Jane. Take us back to when you were born or whatever, you know, when you were 13, whichever age you'd like, and the story of how you got to Rust. Well, I'll start with, you know, I got into programming right before college and took a CS degree and C++ is basically the main language I learned in my program and so went into my professional life doing C++ coding I would not say that I was ever any level of expert or particularly engaged with C++ it was like at that point it was mostly just a job and so like I learned about like L values and R values like embarrassingly late in my C++ career and things like that. And so like, definitely would never classified myself as a C++ expert, like even like
我绝对不会把自己归类为 C++ 专家，甚至在我开始学习 Rust 的时候，我依然不是那种经常依赖模板或 C++ 许多花哨特性的人。我敢肯定，我说这是个花哨特性会让你们这些 C++ 观众觉得，“天哪，她根本不是真正的 C++ 程序员。”我敢肯定，我说这是个花哨特性会让你们这些 C++ 观众觉得“天哪，她根本不是真正的 C++ 程序员”。我觉得比较友善的人非常宽容，但我曾在 Reddit 上看到过诸如“哦，你连这个特性都不知道，那你就根本不懂 C++”之类的言论，而我的想法是，我觉得所有真正的专家都会同意我的看法，所有初学者和所有真正的专家都会同意。只有那些半懂不懂的人，也就是处在曲线中间的人，才会觉得“哦，怎么会有人不知道怎么用模板呢，
towards when I started learning Rust, I was still like, not someone who frequently leaned on templates or many of the fancier features of C++. I'm sure me saying that's a fancier features like your C++ viewers are like, Oh my god, she's not really a C++ and I'm sure me saying that's a fancier feature is like your C++ viewers are like oh my god she's not really a C++ programmer I think the nice ones are very forgiving but I have seen on reddit like oh you don't know this feature well then you don't know C++ and I'm just like I think all the true experts would agree with you like all the beginners all the beginners and all the true experts would agree. It's only the intermediate, like the folks in the middle of the curve who would be like, oh, not everybody knows how to use templates.
这不是很简单吗”。是的，我很赞同这一点。然后，在我的第三份正式工作里，那是一家叫做 Scale Computing 的公司，做的是集群虚拟机监控程序（hypervisor）之类的花样。我们当时在搞黑客之夜（maker nights），在做一个项目。这就是我是如何接触到 Rust 的故事，只是为了说明……所以在我的思绪飘得太远、让人纳闷“她到底在扯哪门子淡”之前，我们当时正在做一个项目，要做出一个字面意义上的红色按钮，用来启动测试套件。这个测试套件在我们内部的一个叫做 Canon 的进程中，它会针对我们拥有的集群的每一种硬件变体，把每一个测试运行多次，
They're so easy. Yeah, I appreciate that. And then, so into my third job professionally at a place called Scale Computing that does like clustered hypervisor shenanigans um we were doing like maker nights or and we were doing a project to this is like the story of how i got introduced to rust just you know and so before i go too deep into this tangent it's like where the hell is she going um and so we're we're doing this project to make a like literal red button to start the test suite that is like within our own like process called the canon which just like tests every test against every hardware variation of cluster we have um like multiple times because it's a bunch of like
因为里面有一堆会出现偶发失败的不稳定测试。所以我们想做一个滑稽的红色按钮，你只要给它一个构建版本，按下按钮，转动钥匙，它就会发出一些傻乎乎的音效，然后向服务器发送一个 JSON 请求并将其启动。对于那个项目，我们在想，
inconsistent tests that have spurious failures uh and so we wanted to make a comical red button that would be able to, you give it a build and you hit the button and you turn the key and it makes some silly sound effects and sends a JSON request to the server and gets it started. And for that project, we're like,
我们想怎么实现这个东西？当时的选择有 Python，我们都懂 Python，而且知道它行得通。然后我的朋友乔希（Josh）说，我们可以试试 Rust。我们谁都不懂 Rust。于是我查了一下，我记得我看到维基百科上的文章说，这门语言表面上类似于 C 和 C++，但从语义上来说，它其实更类似于 ML 家族的语言。在我早期的某份工作里，我曾和一些加州理工学院教授级别的人物一起开发四旋翼飞行器，其中一个人被亲切地描述为“函数式编程怪咖”。
how do we want to implement this thing? And the options were like, we could do Python, which we all know, and we know it would work. And then my friend Josh was like, we could try out Rust. None of us know Rust. So I was looking it up, and I remember seeing the Wikipedia article where it says something along the lines, this language superficially resembles C and C++, but like semantically or semantically, it's actually more akin to the ML family of languages. And from one of my earlier jobs where I had worked on quadcopters with some like Caltech professor people that had like one of them was, I would say lovingly, described as a functional programming weenie.
他对 ML、OCaml 以及一堆此类程序非常痴迷。我记得他曾让我用 XSLT 做过一个大项目，把一个 XML 文档转换成 C++、Java 和 Python，用于解析遥测数据的各种结构体。我记得我有，他曾向我灌输了对 ML 的尊重和某种兴趣，但我从未真正深入其中。我从没真正花时间去学习。当我看到这个时，我想，哦，这听起来真的很酷。就像我想了解这个。所以就像，好吧，我们来学 Rust 吧。
And so very into ML, OCaml, and a bunch of these programs. I remember him having me do a big project in XSLT to do like take an xml document and generate c++ and java and python for a bunch of like struct parsing for telemetry data i remember i had he had instilled in me a respect for ml and something like an interest but i had never really gotten into it i'd never really actually taken the time to learn and so i see this i'm like oh that sounds like something really interesting. Like, I want to learn about this. And so it's like, yeah, let's do Rust.
然后我很快就爱上了它，并开始尽可能地在所有地方使用它。主要是一些工具链，实际上，比如我们有一堆 bash 脚本，用来协助远程开发和日常工作流。我对这些脚本一直很不满，因为 bash 的错误处理简直烂透了。如果你了解我对 Rust 的参与，我会提到我的另一项工作是担任错误处理项目组的负责人。这两者是相关的。所以，我基本上开始把所有这些带有糟糕错误处理的 bash 开发者工具用 Rust 重写，并且我在错误处理上投入了大量精力。最终，我对当时错误处理的现状仍然感到沮丧。我深入研究了一下，弄清楚了问题所在，并开始对语言本身进行更改和提议。
And very quickly fell in love and started using it for everything I could. Mostly tooling for like, actually, like we had like a bunch of bash scripts for like, like helping with remote development and just general workflows stuff that I was always angry at because bash just has horrible error handling and if you know anything about my rust involvement I'm one of the other things I do is I'm the the lead of the error handling project group these are related factors so I got into basically like rewriting all this developer tooling from bash with horrible error handling into rust where I would put a lot of effort into the error handling. And I ended up still being frustrated with kind of the state of error handling at that time. And looked into it, figured out kind of what the problems were and started making changes and proposals to the
从那以后，这多多少少像滚雪球一样，让我更深度地参与进来了。我想中间我漏掉了一个步骤：在我学习这门语言的时候，我想提升自己体验或知识的方法之一，就是为开源项目做贡献，并与那些真正是专家的人合作，
language itself. And that has since more or less snowballed into being more deeply involved. I guess there's like a step in the middle I missed where when I was learning the language, one of the ways that I wanted to improve my experience or improve my knowledge was by like doing contributions to the open source project and like working with people who were actually like experts
从而获得第一手的、与真正懂行的人共事的体验。所以我为 Clippy（那个代码检查工具）做了很多贡献，在加入其他团队之前，我最终先加入了 Clippy 团队。对，从 Clippy 团队开始，我转向了错误处理。然后因为错误处理，我加入了 Libs 团队。我想在那期间我开始……对于听众来说，为什么你对 Rust 爱得这么深沉？如果别人愿意的话，其他人也能这样吗？我觉得，对，显然我觉得其他人
just to kind of get firsthand exposure to people who really knew what they're doing. And so I did a bunch of contributions to Clippy, the linter, and ended up joining the Clippy team before I joined any of the other teams. But yeah, from the Clippy team, I did error handling. And then because of the error handling, I joined the Libs team. And I think between those was when I started for the listeners is why did you fall so deeply in love with rust and can others too if they want to i i think i yeah obviously i think other people
绝对也可以爱上它。对，我觉得对大我而言最重要的一点是，它感觉有更少的“尖锐棱角”，而且它让我能够把更多我必须思考的事情卸载给语言和类型系统，这让我感觉在 C++ 中做不到。我确信 C++ 的一部分问题只是我个人的经验不足。但对于 Rust 来说，虽然一开始确实有很多东西要学，但其 trait（特征）系统感觉要直观得多。它对我来说非常有意义。我知道 C++ 现在也有了 concepts（概念），我想，它们其实……它们不怎么好，所以……好吧。
can definitely follow with it um i think the the big things for me is it has it feels like it has fewer sharp corners and like it lets it feel like it lets me offload more kind of like of the like the things i have to think about onto the language and the like the type system then i felt like i couldn't c++ and i'm sure some of the c++ stuff was just like personal inexperience um but with rust it while it was like definitely a lot to learn up front, the trait system feels like a lot more intuitive. And it just makes a lot of sense to me. I know that C++ now has concepts, I think, which are like... They're not great, so... Okay.
它们达不到 Rust trait 的水平。是的。所以拥有 trait 系统使得泛型变得有意义，以一种模板对我来说从未真正明了的方式变得说得通。我曾经见过、也处理过包含各种 SFINAE 和杂七杂八东西的代码，但我自己从来无法流利地写出 SFINAE 的代码。但只需添加一个 where 子句，要求它拥有这个接口，然后你就可以像处理拥有该接口的类型一样去处理那个类型。
They fall short of what rust traits are. Yeah. And so like having the trait system made like generic, something that actually made like a lot of sense in a way that templates were never really obvious to me. Um, like I could, I had seen, I had worked on code that had like spination and againigans, but I had never been able to fluently output spin A stuff myself. But being able to just add a where bound, require that it has this interface, and then now you can work with that type like it has that.
而且它确实如此，因为编译器会确保只有带有该接口的类型才能传入另一端。C++ 至少能做到这一点，但 C++ 存在的问题——这大概也是你会赞同的一点——是，如果你的东西不满足要求，C++ concepts 并没有一个很好的模型来告诉你它究竟是以什么特定方式不满足要求的。因此你得不到清晰的诊断信息。你只会得到类似“嘿，
And it does, because the compiler will make sure that only types with that interface get passed in another side. C++ can do at least that much, but the problem that C++ has, and this will probably be something that you'll appreciate, is that if your thing doesn't satisfy the requirements, C++ concepts don't really have a good model for how to tell you it doesn't satisfy it in this particular way. And so you don't really get a clear diagnostic. You're just like, hey,
你不满足这个概念”的提示。如果这个概念类似于 regular（常规类型）这种由一堆其他概念组合而成的概念，你就要花上好几个小时去弄清楚你究竟是哪里不符合这些要求。是的，编译器的诊断信息绝对是 Rust 的一大加分项。向埃斯特班（Esteban）致敬，他做出了非常出色的工作，为编译器错误信息付出努力的许多其他人也是如此。我做的错误处理跟那完全没有关系。所以我对他们只有尊敬，功劳全归他们。我觉得很有趣的是，到目前为止你还没有提到
you didn't satisfy this one concept. And if that concept is something like regular, which is a concept that's composed of a bunch of other concepts, you're going to go spend hours trying to figure out exactly how you failed to meet these requirements. Yeah, the compiler diagnostics are definitely, I think, a big plus for Rust. Esteban, shout out, does really great work, as do many other people who work on the compiler's error messages. The error handling I do has nothing to do with that. And so I have nothing but respect. And no credit is mine. I find it interesting that what you haven't said thus far
整个内存安全的问题。我想特别是从 C++ 世界过来的人，很多人会觉得，哦，那就是 Rust 的特色。我的意思是，我认为这当然是 Rust 项目起源的主要动机之一。但在我看来，Rust 似乎已经超越了这一点。对我最有吸引力的 Rust 特质是这门语言的价值观、它的目标，你知道的，把易用性和简单性作为目标。对诊断信息、新用户引导（onboarding）的关注，其演进过程的强大，以及它的现代化程度。这些才是我觉得 Rust 吸引我的地方。
is the whole memory safety thing. And I think especially from the C++ world, a lot of people are like, oh, that's like the feature of Rust. And I mean, I think that was certainly one of the main motivations behind the origins of the Rust project. But it seems to me like Rust has sort of grown beyond that. And like the thing that's appealing, most appealing to Rust about me is sort of like the values of the language, like its goals, you know, having sort of ease of use and simplicity be a goal. The focus on, you know, diagnostics on onboarding new users, the strength of its evolution process, how modern it is. Like that's all what's attractive to me about Rust.
这跟内存安全完全没有关系。但我猜很多 C++ 的人只是单纯地认为，哦，这全都是关于内存安全的。是的，我想我有时确实把内存安全视作理所当然了。所以它甚至不是我经常需要担心的事情。当然在某些场景下它超级重要，但我甚至不喜欢在不安全的内存环境中工作。我想，有很多焦虑是我不必再去担心的，我感觉编译器在为我撑腰。当然，只要我一触碰 unsafe，那种焦虑就会卷土重来，但随后，这就像
And that's, you know, has nothing to do with the memory safety thing. But I think a lot of C++ people just assume, oh, it's all about the memory safety. Yeah, I think I definitely, I think I take the memory safety for granted sometimes. And so it's like, it's not even something I worry about very often. And there's definitely contexts where it's like super important, but I just, I just don't even like to work in a memory and sleep environment. Like, I guess there's a lot of anxiety that I don't have to worry about as well. That it's just, I feel like the compiler has my back. I mean, as soon as I touch unsafe, that anxiety comes back, but then I, it's like
是一种范围更小的焦虑，我能够把它发给一堆朋友或者用 Miri 运行它。有很多方法可以确保在这方面一切正常。用什么运行？Miri，那个解释器。啊对，它是对抽象机器的实现，它会进行栈借用检查（stacked borrows），拉尔夫·容（Ralph Jung）的博士研究成果全都倾注在里面了，里面有一些非常惊人的技术。我们学到了新东西。是的，它很慢。我听说他们正在加速，但它依然挺慢的，所以你不会用它来跑一整套复杂的 Web 服务器之类的，但你可以用它来跑测试，特别是在库开发中，你可以用 Miri 非常好地验证不安全（unsafe）的抽象。
a much more scoped anxiety and I'm able to like like send it to like a bunch of friends or run it through Mary and there's like a bunch of ways to kind of still make sure that everything's good in that regard run it through what Mary the interpreter ah yeah it's the it's like the implementation of the abstract machine and it will it stacked borrows there's all of Ralph Ralph Young's uh PhD work has gone into that and it's got some amazing technology in it. We learned something new. Yeah it's slow though. I think they're speeding it up but it's still pretty slow so you're not going to run like whole ass like web servers through it or anything but you can you can do tests and especially on libraries you can verify unsafe abstractions pretty nicely with
是的，社区是一个大因素。我一直觉得，这对我个人在 C++ 和 Rust 之间的体验上造成了巨大的差异。我以前从未真正想过——我多年来一直想为开源做贡献，在接触 Rust 之前，但从未真正找到方法，也没有勇气跳进去。一旦我接触了 Rust，我开始关注《本周 Rust》（This Week in Rust），那是他们的周报播客。特别是当我刚开始的时候，他们在从代码仓库以及 Clippy、rust-fmt 等相关项目中挑选适合新手的友好议题（good first issues）方面做得非常好。看到那种持续的行动号召，让人很容易找到切入点，这确实带来了截然不同的体验，
mary yeah community is a big one i i think that like that was a huge difference for for me personally with c++ and with rust it was like i never really figured like i'd wanted to do open source contributions for years before like i got involved in rust but never never really found a way to do it or like comfort jumping in. And once I got involved in Rust, I started following This Week in Rust, which is their weekly podcast. And especially back when I started, they were really good about putting lots of good first issues from the repo and some of the associated projects like clippy and rust rust uh rust format and things like that and just like seeing that like kind of that steady call for action like kind of making it easy to find places to jump in really kind of made the difference between
不再让我感到焦虑和犹豫，而是让我觉得，你知道吗？好吧，我来试试看。当然，这并非一帆风顺。确实有那么几个 PR，我提交之后就石沉大海了。所以我也经历了一番摸索，才找到了项目中那些评审速度相对较快的板块，
um being anxious and like kind of hesitant or like just being like you know what okay i'll give this a shot and it definitely it wasn't like a completely bumpy unbumpy ride there were definitely like a few PRs where I opened it up and just like kind of got crickets and so it took me a little bouncing around to find a part of the project that where the reviews kind of came along faster um and you know where I wasn't anxious and just worrying that people weren't replying because I was doing something wrong you know on me but eventually I did find that with Clippy so yeah
在那里我不用焦虑，也不会担心别人不回复是因为我做错了什么。但最终我在 Clippy 这里找到了这样的体验。所以，是的。
Clippy I just discovered Clippy today shout out to Mike Dom who just randomly pinged me today on discord and I guess knew that I had said something on Twitter about trying to out rust a little bit. And like, yeah, like, I mean, there's so much amazing things I could say about Rust,
我今天刚发现 Clippy。向迈克·多姆（Mike Dom）致敬，他今天在 Discord 上随机戳了我一下，我猜他知道我在 Twitter 上说过想尝试一下 Rust。然后，是的，我的意思是，关于 Rust 我可以赞美的东西太多了，
but Rust Clippy, I was like, oh, first I got to go install it. And then, so I ran some, you know, command line thing and it was like, it's already installed. Like I did Rust up earlier. So it was already there. And then I just did Rust. What did I do? I did cargo Clippy and then it was already there. And then I just did rust. What did I do? I did cargo clippy. And then it gave me a bunch of lint stuff.
但关于 Rust Clippy，我想，哦，我得先去安装它。然后我运行了一些命令行指令，它提示说：已经安装好了。就像我之前运行过 rustup 一样。所以它已经在那里了。然后我直接运行了 Rust。我刚才做了什么？我运行了 cargo clippy，它就已经在那里了。然后它给我了一堆代码检查（lint）结果。
One of them was actually something I Googled earlier. I had one of these, you know, I wanted to see if X was either zero or one. So in the bounds of zero or one and not outside of it. And there's a couple of different idiomatic ways to do this in different languages like Python, you know, blah, blah, blah. Anyways, it doesn't matter. I had just, it was like, screw it. I couldn't really find a stack overflow, like idiomatic thing.
其中一个正是我早些时候在 Google 上搜索过的问题。我有这样一个需求，我想检查 X 是等于 0 还是 1。也就是在 0 或 1 的范围内，而不是范围之外。在不同语言中有几种不同的地道写法，比如 Python，等等等等。总之，无所谓。我当时想，去他的吧。我实在没在 Stack Overflow 上找到地道的写法。
There was a couple of different answers. So I was like, oh, just do the naive thing. And then cargo clippy, it tells me like, oh, you should do like a exclamation paren zero dot dot equal one n paren dot contains. And then my value, I assuming that exclamation mark means it's like a compile time range or something. Anyway, I don't even know what was going on, but I was like, wow, that's amazing. Like it literally gave me the idiomatic version of what I wanted of something that I Googled
有几种不同的答案。所以我当时想，好吧，就用最朴素的写法吧。然后 cargo clippy 告诉我，哦，你应该写类似叹号括号 0 两个点等于 1 右括号点 contains。然后是我的值。我猜那个叹号意味着它是一个编译时范围之类的东西？不管怎样，我当时甚至不知道是怎么回事，但我心想，哇，太厉害了！它简直直接给出了我想要的、我刚才在 Google 上搜索却找不到答案的那种地道写法。
for and like, couldn't find the answer. And then they've just got a dash dash fix, which is like the first thing I checked as I like, That was me. Do I really? Oh my goodness. I added cargo clippy fix. Yeah. Thank you, Jane.
而且他们还有一个 --fix 选项，我检查的第一件事就是……那是我的功劳吗？哦天哪。我加了 cargo clippy fix。是的。谢谢你，简。
It was, it was wonderful. And then I told him, I instantly committed it to this, my little toy repo, sent it to Mike. And then Mike was saying, oh, I actually, I like to, you know,
这太棒了。然后我告诉了他，我立即把这个改动提交到了我的小玩具代码库里，发给了迈克。然后迈克说，哦，其实我喜欢，
manually fix them to sort of get it more ingrained in my memory. And I was like, you know, I reviewed everything. It was basically just deleting a bunch of unnecessary clones, changing some into itters into itters, which, you know, full disclosure, I don't understand the difference. I'm like, I, and that's the thing about, do you want to know? We'll get, we'll get, I want to know. I, I basically, I feel like I'm sprinting most of the time,
手动修复它们，以便更好地将它们印在记忆里。我说，你知道的，我检查了所有改动，基本上就是删除了许多不必要的克隆（clone），把一些 into_iter 改成了 iter（注：原文如此），老实说，我不懂这两者的区别。我心想，这就是……你想知道吗？我们会讲到的，我想知道。我基本上觉得自己大部分时间都在狂奔，
even though I don't know rust at all. And this is something that John or JT, Jonathan Turner said on a Go versus Rust panel, is that because it's got so much safety baked into the language, when you do PR reviews and stuff, you don't actually have to worry about a whole set of code review things. And when he said that, I realized it's like, wow, I don't actually know what I'm doing. But you're kind of allowed to run with knives in Rust because like the compiler won't let you stab yourself or shoot yourself in the foot. Like not for everything. I'm sure.
尽管我根本不懂 Rust。正如乔恩或 JT（乔纳森·特纳，Jonathan Turner）在一个 Go 与 Rust 的座谈会上所说，因为 Rust 在语言中内置了如此多的安全性，当你进行 PR 评审之类的工作时，你实际上根本不用担心整整一大类代码评审问题。当他说完那句话时，我意识到，哇，我其实根本不知道自己在干什么。但在 Rust 里，你有点像被允许拿着刀跑步，因为编译器不会让你捅伤自己或搬起石头砸自己的脚。当然不是在所有事情上都这样。我确信。
I'm sure there's some ways you can run into panics and whatnot, but like logic errors and stuff like it's, that's not like bug free code, but exactly. But there's a whole set of things where like, you're always going to shoot yourself and see your C plus plus. And here, here I am. I'm just like sprinting with the knowledge that I have from every other language. And then every once in a while I run into something where I'm accidentally moving. And you know, I haven't figured out the fact that it's moved by default, but like, I'll get stuck on that for like 10 or 20 minutes and then I'll fix it. I'll be like, okay, now I need to know that I have to do doc copied on this thing. If I am coming from a
我确信你还是会遇到 panic 之类的情况，但诸如逻辑错误之类的事情，虽然这不代表代码完全没有 Bug，但确实如此。不过有一大类问题，在 C++ 里你总是会把自己炸得粉身碎骨。而现在我在这里，带着从其他每门语言中学到的知识一路狂奔。然后每隔一段时间，我会遇到一些不小心触发了 move（所有权转移）的情况。你知道的，我还没习惯默认会被 move 的特性，但我会卡在那儿 10 或 20 分钟，然后把它修好。我会想：好吧，我得记住，如果我是从一个切片（slice）之类的东西开始操作，我需要调用 dot copied。
slice or something. And anyways, then I go back to sprinting with knives and it's like, it be like, okay, now I need to know that I have to do dot copied on this thing. If I am coming from a slice or something. Anyways, then I go back to sprinting with knives and it's like, it's like, that's so amazing. It's like beginners. You can just like get a bunch of people that don't really know what they're doing and just say like, go for it. And like, that's, that's like pretty novel for like not having to hold a beginner's hand and like half the time click Clippy and the compiler, they're just like the compiler messages you're getting is like, did you mean to do this? And I
然后无论如何，我就会继续拿着刀狂奔，感觉就像：好吧，我得记住，如果我是从一个切片之类的东西开始操作，我需要调用 dot copied。无论如何，我就会继续拿着刀狂奔，感觉就像是：这太棒了！初学者们。你可以找一堆根本不懂他们在干什么的人，然后对他们说：“放手去干吧！”这在不需要手把手带初学者这方面绝对算是一种创新。而且有一半时间，Clippy 和编译器给你的编译错误提示就像是在问：“你是这个意思吗？”
was like, well, I don't know, but probably like I look into it and I was like, that is exactly what I was trying to do. Fantastic. Anyways, back to you inter or iter versus into iter. Okay. I also, just before I get into iter versus into it, or also have you checked out the dash dash explains on any of the errors you run into? I have not, because I feel like I did that once on rust playground. And my impression of it is that it just like gives you the same message or something. So clearly my impression of what that does is, is completely incorrect. Yeah, no, it there's basically, there's a bunch of like long form markdown documents,
我心想，好吧，我不知道，但大概是的。我研究了一下，发现：这正是我刚才想实现的效果。太棒了。言归正传，回到 iter 与 into_iter 的区别。对了，在讲 iter 与 into_iter 之前，你有没有试过在你遇到的错误后面加上 --explain 查看解释？我没有，因为我觉得我在 Rust 操场（playground）上试过一次，我当时的印象是它只会给出相同的错误信息什么的。所以显然我对它作用的理解是完全错误的。是的，其实那里有大量长篇的 Markdown 文档，
deep detailing, like, like basically like mini lessons about like pieces of the language for like, that are relevant to error errors. So like if you run into like an error about misusing a trade object and you do like the dash dash explain E, then the number code that represents that that's associated with that error, it'll be like trade objects in Rust work this way and this and this and this. And it gives you like really nice, detailed explanation. And it's a good time. Interesting.
详细介绍了语言各个片段的微型课程，这些片段与错误息息相关。所以，如果你遇到了关于滥用 trait 对象（trait object）的错误，然后你运行了 --explain E 加上与该错误关联的数字代码，它就会解释说：“Rust 中的 trait 对象是这样工作的，巴拉巴拉巴拉。”它会给你非常棒、非常详细的解释。体验很好。很有意思。
And that sort of checks out with something that someone said on the Rust subreddit, is that they said a lot of the times, Stack Overflow actually isn't the place to go. It's like, the Rust docs are so good, and the Rust ecosystem, that a lot of the times you can find the answer in the compiler in the docs or something like that because accessing the first element didn't have, I don't think even one of the answers was dot first or maybe it was and I missed it. I will definitely check that out. Maybe one of these episodes, Bryce and I will do a live coding again, except we'll record it and post it to YouTube. And then we'll, we'll be blown away by these explainer explainer messages. Also, have you seen rust analyzer yet? Yes. That was one of the, I had heard from
这与 Rust Subreddit 上某位网友的说法不谋而合，他们说很多时候 Stack Overflow 真的不是该去的地方。因为 Rust 文档和 Rust 生态系统太棒了，很多时候你都可以在编译器文档中找到答案。例如，获取第一个元素的那个操作，我当时甚至不觉得答案里会有 dot first，或者其实有但我漏掉了。我一定会去看看的。也许在接下来的某集里，布莱斯和我会再次进行实时编码，只不过我们会把它录下来发布到 YouTube 上。然后我们就会被这些解释信息惊艳到。另外，你见过 rust-analyzer 了吗？见过。那是我听说的其中一个工具。
a podcast that had JT on it that he said like, that should be like the number one thing you get, like you rust up and you get cargo. And then you, if you're hopping to VS code or wherever you are, get the rust analyzer. Yeah. It's, it's, it's very, very, it's a very good language server. What is the rust analyzer? It's the language server. So it's like a query based version of the compiler and it shares a lot of the dependencies and implementation with the compiler as well.
有一个请了JT上节目的播客，他提到说，那应该算你首先要做的事情，比如你配置好Rust并获取了Cargo。然后，如果你要切换到VS Code或其他任何地方，安装rust analyzer。是的，它是一个非常非常好的语言服务器。什么是rust analyzer？它是语言服务器。所以它类似于编译器的基于查询的版本，它与编译器共享了许多依赖项和实现。
And so it's like, it's just very fast. Why do I, why do I want it? Like, what is it? It's like the equivalent of having playing the, um, with like all the auto-complete stuff and C++, like without that, you're not getting any suggestions. You're not getting any lint hints. You're not getting any compiler hints. It also has like code actions. So like you can use it to invert expressions, to outline or inline variables, to take some body of a function and automatically split it out into a separate function, things like that. It also lets you jump around.
所以它是，就是非常快。为什么我，为什么我要它？比如，它是什么？这就好比你在C++中使用所有自动补全功能时的体验，如果没有它，你将无法获得任何建议。你无法获得任何代码检查提示。你无法获得任何编译器提示。它还具有类似代码操作的功能。因此，你可以用它来反转表达式、将变量提取到外部或内联、提取函数的主体并自动将其拆分为单独的函数，诸如此类。它还允许你四处跳转。
So you can go to definition on any type or variable. Or if you're on a function function you can be like go to references and a list everywhere that functions used in the code base and you can like really quickly jump through those and there's probably a bunch of other things it's really i think it comes with with rust format as well which and you can set it up to run clippy and all sorts of stuff yeah honestly it's like i get the sense where we would i promise we'll get to the iter versus into iter thing but i feel like like there's other reasons that i'm really liking rust but like one of the things is that it's like c++ but with guaranteed
因此，你可以跳转到任何类型或变量的定义。或者如果你在一个函数上，你可以选择转到引用，它会列出代码库中所有使用该函数的地方，你可以非常快速地在这些地方之间跳转，可能还有很多其他功能，我真的觉得它还自带了rust format，而且你可以将其设置为运行clippy和各种各样的东西。是的，说实话，我有一种感觉，我保证我们会讨论iter和into iter的问题，但我真的觉得除了这些，我喜欢Rust还有其他原因，其中之一就是它就像C++，但有保证
like a bunch of the sanitizers because the memory safety stuff and then like built in from scratch clang format clang tidy a bunch of other stuff c++ 2023 ranges and like everything that we're missing in the iter trait like honestly i basically just used iter the iter trait because it's it's so phenomenal everything that we want in c++ is there in rust you want to numerate it? It's there. You want zip? It's there. You want a bunch of other ones, flat map? It's there. And oh, speaking of flat map or map, the reason Mike Dom pinged me about Clippy was because the message it gave him, it reduced like eight lines of code to a single line that said you have manually implemented option.map. And I was just like, what? How does it? Oh, man, like it's it's you have to see it.
就像内置了许多清理工具，因为有内存安全之类的东西，然后就像从头开始构建的clang format、clang tidy以及许多其他东西、C++ 2023 ranges以及我们在iter trait中错失的一切，说实话，我基本只用iter和iter trait，因为它是如此卓越，我们在C++中想要的一切，Rust里都有。你想枚举它？它在那。你想zip？它在那。你想要其他很多功能，比如flat map？它在那。哦，说到flat map或map，Mike Dom之所以就Clippy的事找我，是因为它给他的提示信息将大约八行代码精简为了一行，上面写着你手动实现了option.map。当时我就想，什么？它是怎么做到的？哦，天哪，你必须亲眼见证它。
I will somehow find a way to post that in the show notes of the diff because it's quite phenomenal. There's some great clippy lids. Tune in next week for part two of this three part interview. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我会想办法把那个差异的节目笔记贴出来，因为它相当惊艳。有一些非常棒的clippy提示。请收听下周的三部分访谈的第二部分。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。